PROFESSOR: That's how
it looks, a resonance.
You can see it basically
in the phase shift.
And great increase of the
phase of almost minutely pi
over a very small
change of energy.
And it should [INAUDIBLE]
with a very big [INAUDIBLE]..
So this is how it looks.
And I want to now
proceed, after if there
are some questions,
of how do we search
for residences a little
more mathematically rather
than plotting them.
How could I write an
equation for a resonance.
Cannot say, oh, the
phase changes fast.
Well, that's not a very
nice way of saying it.
It's good.
It's intuitive.
But we should be
able to do better.
So how do I find resonances?
So let's model
resonances a little bit.
How do we find resonances?
So let's model this behavior.
By that is writing
a formula that
is simple enough that seems
to capture what's happening.
And that formula's
going to inspire
us to think of resonances
perhaps a little more clearly.
So suppose you have a
resonance near k equal alpha.
I claim the following
formula would be a good way
to represent the resonance?
We would say that tan
delta is equal to beta
over alpha minus k.
Or-- yeah, we would say that.
[INAUDIBLE] Or if you wish,
delta is tan minus 1 of beta
over alpha minus k.
Why is that reasonable?
It's a little surprising,
but not that surprising.
You see that-- delta is
equal to minus pi over 2.
The tangent of delta
goes to infinity.
So there's something
going on here in which you
have this property.
So let's plot this.
So let's plot beta
over alpha minus k.
You need a clock
to understand this.
So this is k, and we're
plotting this quantity.
Well, it's going to go
crazy at k equal alpha.
That we know.
When k is less than
alpha, I'm going
to assume that alpha
and beta are positive.
They both have units of k.
And when k is less than
alpha-- we begin here--
then this denominator
is positive,
the numerator is positive,
ratio is positive.
It's small, maybe.
And then suddenly,
when k reaches alpha
it goes to infinity.
So it's going to be like that.
Now, it actually
is true that when
k differs by alpha by
beta, it reaches value 1.
So here is alpha minus beta.
That point it reaches value 1.
So if I want this
thing to be very sharp,
I need beta to be small
so that it's little
until it reaches beta within--
distance beta within alpha,
and then it shoots up.
So I want beta to be
small for sharp behavior.
On the other hand here,
it goes the other way.
It goes from minus
infinity back to 0,
and has value minus
1 at alpha plus beta.
So within minus beta, and
beta off of the center
alpha, most of
the things happen.
If we plot now the
tangent of this,
or the arctangent of this, tan
minus 1 of beta, alpha minus k,
well, if the tangent of
an angle is very little,
the angle can be taken
to be very little.
At this point, it
will reach pi over 2,
so the angle is little,
will go to pi over 2,
and then quickly becomes
larger than pi over 2,
you're thinking tangents.
So the tangent is going up,
is blowing up at pi over 2.
Then continuously, it
goes to minus pi over 2,
and then continuously goes
to 0 so it reaches pi.
So this is the
behavior of delta.
Delta is this tan minus
1 of beta over that.
And delta is doing
the right thing.
It's doing this
kind of behavior.
There is a shift.
I could add a constant
here to produce this shift,
but it's not important
at this moment.
The resonance is
doing this thing,
up to a total shift
of pi that doesn't
change the tangent of an angle.
So this is one way
of modeling what's
happening to the phase
shift near our resonance.
So let's explore
it a little more.
I can do a couple
of calculations.
For example, I can compute
what is d delta dk at k
equals alpha.
That's should be
a nice quantity.
Is a derivative of the face.
At the resonance,
at the position
alpha of the resonance.
So here's delta, here
is k, and there's
the derivative of this k.
And how should it be?
Well, basically, the
phase changes by amount pi
over a distance beta or 2 beta.
So this must be a
number divided by beta.
You can calculate this
derivative from this equation.
It's a nice exercise.
It's actually just 1 over beta.
That's a result. 1 over beta.
The other quantity that
is nice to understand
is how does this
scattering amplitude
behave near the resonance.
So what is the
value of as squared?
Oh, that's the absolute
value of psi s squared,
which is sine squared delta.
That's the same
thing as As squared.
Well, you know what is
the tangent of delta?
A little trigonometric play
should be able to do it,
and can give you the
sin squared delta.
And here is the answer.
It's beta squared over
beta squared plus alpha
minus k squared.
Kind of a nice,
almost bell shape.
Of course, it's polynomial,
but it looks a little
like just a nice symmetric
shape around alpha equal k.
Now, this division is so famous
it has been given a name.
It's called the
Breit-Wigner distribution.
Breit-Wigner.
But it's described as the
Breit-Wigner distribution,
and it's usually referring
to terms of energy.
Of energy, not momentum.
So-- and it's--
what should happen to
scattering amplitude in general
when you have a resonance.
So the way to do
this calculation now
is to say, well, what
is alpha minus k?
Let's try to relate it to the
energy minus the energy at k
equal alpha.
Well, this is h
squared k squared
over 2 m minus h squared
alpha squared over 2 m,
which is h squared over 2 m,
k squared minus alpha squared.
On the other hand, I have
here alpha minus k squared.
I don't have k squared
minus alpha squared.
So-- approximations.
if the resonance is narrow
enough, if beta is small,
let's do an approximation.
We do h squared over--
everybody knows
this approximation,
shouldn't be afraid of doing it.
It's alpha-- how
could I write it--
k minus alpha
times k plus alpha.
And the approximation is that
all the interesting thing
comes from the difference
between k and alpha,
how close k is to alpha.
So when k is close to
alpha, all the dependence
is going to be here.
This is going to be about 2
alpha when k is near alpha.
And if it's a little
more than that,
it doesn't matter,
because it's [INAUDIBLE]..
So this could be
approximated to 2 alpha,
and therefore this becomes h
squared alpha over m times k
minus alpha.
So that's a little help.
Then size of s squared,
doing a little more
of algebra with the
constants there.
Probably you want to
do it with two lines.
It's tricky.
It's really simple.
It's always written
in this form--
1 over 4 gamma squared over
e minus e alpha squared
plus 1 over four gamma
squared, and that's
the so-called
Breit-Wigner distribution.
And gamma is a
funny constant here.
We'll try to
understand it better.
2 alpha beta h squared over m.
It has to be something that
depends on alpha and beta,
because after all,
we weren't modeling
the resonance with alpha beta.
So this curve is very famous.
That's the distribution of
the scattering amplitude
over energies whenever
you have a resonance.
So we should plot it.
You have an e alpha.
You have an e alpha
plus gamma over 2
and e alpha minus gamma over 2.
But the energy minus e alpha
is equal to the gamma over 2,
you get the gamma squared over
4 so the total amplitude goes
down to 1/2 of the
usual amplitudes.
When the energy is equal
to e alpha, you get 1.
1 for psi s squared.
But when the energy differs
from e alpha by gamma over 2,
you get half.
So-- actually, I'm not
sure of the deflection
point, where it is.
Probably not there.
Or is it there?
I don't know.
I drew it as if it is there.
So that's the distribution, and
the width over here is gamma.
So gamma is called the
width at half power,
or at half intensity.
Yeah.
Width-- the half width
of the distribution.